hello and welcome to the lobby
gamespot's weekly hang out every tuesday
at two p.m. pacific right here on video
games com or on twitch.tv for Asajj
gamespot or in your ears wherever you
are in podcast lon hello my name is
Daniel Dwyer i'm your host this week
apologies in advance though if i'm
speaking like I'm drunk it's not that
Irish thing it's actually that I got a
bunch of wisdom teeth pulled out last
week so I'm a little bit this that this
will be the most i've actually like
properly talked in basically week so
apologies in advance coulda been worse
though could have got a root canal
speaking of roots ty routier as a great
segue very much I mean pro that was one
that was the only time I can ever use
that also eric taze here what's up Tay
and I yeah but we're black shirts too
great it's gonna be really great grass
or smoking a turd how many of your
shirts have sold by the way I don't know
I didn't look so what you blame teh
hashtag blame Tay oops you are our good
friend who gave us these wonderful balls
of Nuka Cola quantum and he put it up on
T spring or something yeah great so I've
tweeted at the lanczos gamespot so if
you want a picture of Eric's [ __ ]
cartoon nas face on it with hashtag
dente on the back III t-shirt it's the e
3 t shirts gonna wear it out all the
whole crew the correct okay yeah blink a
that's just really confused the branding
yeah real hard yeah well in case
something breaks it makes perfect sense
exactly don't jinx it now I know there's
a good chance things will break cuz
you've taken over III responsibilities
would like two months ago he takes over
everything has up in its gonna be fine
nobody noticed he actually started show
and just running on his nest oh there
you go there it is having a bad day car
broke down boss on your back PSN down no
audio on your life scream perilous play
day there you go Ashley I plant a go
pick it up thank you so much both of you
for joining me today talk about all
things video games i doing a bad job of
trying not to speak so I'm gonna let you
guys take over for a little while ty
Rouge tell me about your time playing
the division this week I hear it I hear
it's a real glitch festival I feel gross
really you played it some friends you
had a good time I still feel gross
it's like one of those things were like
you know what you're doing is just a
complete waste of time you can buy
something way better with your time but
you just stick it out and then doing
this nice weather on the weekend it's
always beautiful yeah I actually made
myself go outside twice cuz it was just
like this is dumb so it so it explains
me what you're doing you're playing the
division with some of your buddies I
here I heard from Erin who has been
playing the division basically non stop
since it came out yeah what about a
bunch you guys gonna happen on and off I
hear it as a bunch of sort of exploits
going on there but it seemed like that
stuff really cranked into high gear
right yeah well I mean it's been going
on at least about the entire duration
I've been playing the game and I think I
started playing a lot on Thursday maybe
wednesday of last week pretty
aggressively you know multiple like you
know two to three hours a night and then
on the weekends man i'm just playing it
all day but i was playing with some guys
and it's just crew i run with and
they're always like geared out to the
max and and did you also play with them
in the crew know another property you
saw a title proof no okay no i didn't
didn't go across no you did also [ __ ]
lot you know you did with me and I'm
bill I mean that was the only time i
played it when we tried to go to San
Francisco yeah visit her hometown whose
great we go to e3 we did we finished
that the cohesive anyway sorry sorry the
division um yeah anyways so I play with
these guys they're both geared all a
good crew of people and essentially they
showed me a bunch of exploits like what
people have been doing I guess for the
last two weeks three weeks or maybe
since the games come out I have no idea
but it was it was bizarre stuff we're
like it the the incursion just came
outside on the deal say they've released
and I had never beaten the incursion on
challenging okay what you're seeing
right now is the actual glitch itself so
um but the idea is you go down this
ladder you go through this tunnel and
you did basically you can just skip
everything you have to worry about in
terms of like these 15 waves of enemies
coming and then using some weird like
cover glitch where you go from one cover
to the next you can climb up basically
through the world yeah into this
nebulous blue room like maybe a part of
the game that the massive will expand
upon and ya later DLC yeah there's a
hobo they're out there they gave some to
do so yeah one bottle to give her a
bottle water she'll give you like an
article of clothing or gone it is like a
city
environment of anyways you go around and
then you can actually see this weird
grey wall you can actually see where
you're supposed to be you see the APC
and you can just go up there and just
start firing sticky bombs which usually
has like waves of stuff around yeah so
once you initiate that you get like 15
waves of enemies that I think the
incursion itself on challenging again
I've never successfully done it on
challenging yeah I know it can take
people up to an hour if not more right
yeah that's probably longer if your
groups not that strong because there's
like way higher level enemies and
whatnot just that like last week's
glitch was already kind of bad but this
one that thi showed me I just like this
is pretty ridiculous that's why you're
climbing a fake ladder through the world
yeah and then on top of that you're
shooting the APC through like an
invisible wall so to speak and no and
the NPC's can get you sometimes so you
just said this week's glitch so it's
like like that like DLC drop so I was
lots of things last week's glitch you
could just use the barricade type thing
or if you had two people could kind of
shield glitch each other through a wall
in the incursion life and the way that
worked was like okay as long as you
don't go through the main window none of
the enemies see you or like do anything
to you as long as you don't go to a
certain area yeah and you're just
standing right next to the APC and you
just sticky mada till it dies yeah but
this week's new exploit which i have no
idea how people figure this out they
must be like testers or something I
again the crew I was with me I don't
know where they learn they heard of
major showed me part of them a girl who
hurt my god by the way there's also
multiple ways to do that exactly which
it's currently I don't even think it's
fixed as of today but there's multiple
ways to do it they just showed me this
way through the world you walk up this
invisible ladder then you start firing
your sticky bomb at it but I will say
this with the group of four and yeah
they're all decked out with high skill
power you can take that thing down in
like 30 minutes and you can still get
around to pick up your drop afterwards
but yeah so what happens is especially
if it's a weekly challenge you get like
you get your reward immediately which is
like a level 240 piece of gear and then
you can actually fast travel to the
beginning of the mission right go down
the sewer like you were going to
normally do go all the way it's like
empty empty because it's like oh you
beat it you're done in your drop is
still there so I saw one
today as well that had somebody
glitching into a wall in the dark zone
that was just a stone glitch now okay
apparently you can you can again the
same wallhack method that Eric was
talking about yeah and the first this is
just a deployable cover thing there's
just loads of like yeah we're next
lights happening with that thing yeah I
mean that's what people are using now to
just go through any wall essentially at
this point and I believe there's even
more glitches where you can get into the
like get into that weird again Blue Room
yeah white room level area we can like
shoot through walls but that's what this
person is doing in this one where they
can go into the safe house without
actually entering it using that let
mobile cover glitch and then they can
shoot players as they're trying to enter
the safe zone like you know this
particular safe zone 2 has a vendor that
sells high-end gear so people are going
there to like either restock on mo all
right I in gear they can get shot and
killed so at that point the guy that's
doing the glitch can level up his rank
and the dark zone I don't know how fast
or effective it would be but essentially
they're just going rogue and then
outlasting their rogue timer or manhunt
timer all right Alex it's like step back
away from this for a second because like
obviously can we can chat and say oh my
god this guy's broke above like glitches
are part and parcel of a lot of online
games and you fell out destiny does this
like there were exploits within a lot of
the yeah like for the glass and stuff
there was like waiting you can like skip
through parts and one not like to be
honest like I think about like why
rating I was almost part of the
challenge was I know finding out like
the the best tactic and like itching you
know going through walls is one thing
maybe but like you know being able to
like skip certain parts of molten core
was always like good sort of a good
thing does this seem more egregious in
the division it's only more egregious
because of how the system or how the
game works so right now incursion which
is the thing that's getting exploited
the most is offering players the highest
tier of loot that you can get in the
game and it's I think it's like
currently the only place you can get it
so of course people are going to exploit
it right because it's like not only is
it so much faster than doing it normally
but it's really the only place you can
get it at yeah so in a way it's it's
kind of almost like there's something
wrong with the design of the game
potentially only because like it's such
a loot driven game and this exploit is
basically really harming the game
because you have your demographic that
you know like the hardcore or whoever
that are you know exporting all the time
and then you have your casual players or
your people that have high ethics and
they don't want to exploit and then
they're like well like massive should
punish these people and like the
community manager I think I'm massive is
even come outside like they're looking
into punishing people but it's like
weird because you can't really do that
because it's in the game right it's in
your game you have to fix your game well
it's like this is difference between
like you know rage critters in street
fighter 5 and then people who are
basically taking yeah yeah but you know
exposing the holes in your product this
is what's happening here this is people
in my opinion at least talking to the
people i play with I asked them why they
did it you know and like it's like
leveling the playing field whites Rove
you to do know is it's an interesting
question to pose to somebody because I
don't have all day to play this game you
know and I'm a casual player you know
like these people are playing hours and
hours a day but the main response I got
to that was this is the only way I can
even catch up and and at least somewhat
compete in the dark zone when people are
out there with super high-end rider and
there's like they have like really high
armor capacity they can basically take a
ton of damage and when they're in the
dark zone just wrecking shop going rogue
and annihilating people if you wanna if
you want to catch up if you want to
compete and you don't want to die
immediately you kind of have to do it so
you know it's like it's like the Tour de
France and cycling you know it's like
everyone's doping so I'm gonna [ __ ]
dope you know because I knew I want to
compete you know and if everyone's doing
it then you have to do it although your
the Lance Armstrong of exactly with one
testicle it's it's just it is annoying
though like and I and I grant like
granite I agree with Arik like half they
have to fix this this is a problem but
it also speaks more to their design of
the dark zone because like Elise in
destiny when you play multiplayer
everyone's kind of like on the same
level more that's it's like teamed at
myspace it's like skill right whereas
it's cool that the division has like
this unique dynamic we're like you know
you can go in there and wreck shop but
like if you have people that are just
getting all this monster gear yeah and
they can't be killed easily and they're
annihilating everybody then it's like
what happened to the dark zone at that
point I mean the dogs amazon I mean the
dachshund always seem like justice not
like an afterthought but almost like
they had that grand scope idea when they
wanted the division to be this sort of
like immersive always
connected online game would like these
you know I compile up with people that
you might run into other people which
was not the game they ended up launching
and she always felt like dark zone was
just as kind of like remnant like this
leftover parsh yeah that's sort of like
stuck to the rest of the game so I I
think what's interesting about this is
when when I I used to be in game dev
briefly for like 18 months and I
remember like when the game launched we
were working on devs can blow doubt go
by loadout yeah and even know if it's
for sale still available but uh I know
that there's a there's a temptation for
devs to just react to everything really
quickly write a lot like feedback from
the community yeah like they'll they'll
just kind of especially if it's like a
you know smaller dev rice but um if you
go there reddit on division that's
insane right it's a lot of people
complaining and some of its rightfully
so so if it's just kind of like you know
hey like this is the state of the game
calm down but I think there is this
tendency for didactic whicli to things
and I think that's kind of what massive
is doing sometimes cuz like there are
times where I thought maybe they thought
the game was too easy so they made it
super hard drives people and then after
the beta dot Poppins yeah okay and then
even after this latest patch like you
know I remember playing the game one
like man I'm like I'm like a lot more
I'm like a piece of glass now it's like
you know one bullet and I'm dead like
these guys are shotgunning me like these
are just in pcs like your regular people
so you're saying they're like they're
like papering the cracks but in doing so
it's like somewhere else it's not it's
possible yeah i know i'm not saying
that's exactly what they're doing but i
know that they're quick to react and i
know that the game has definitely
changed and like up and down kind of all
over the place since i started playing
and so I'm a little concerned that maybe
they're being too reactive I don't know
I mean it's just again like I have to
imagine massive has a pretty big squad
and there and there and this is by the
way this is like a completely different
game that I worked on so it is it's like
no not even the same but it's just it's
interesting to see how they're trying to
fix everything I mean this is this is
going to be a very hard time for them
like just in terms of like now and what
they've had and like up like what they
have coming because they're at a point
where their fanbase is starting to kind
of get you know more critical more upset
and they might lose player base right
and they got to figure it out like
destiny it took them a year for them to
finally kind of get it like good like
figure out quality of life stuff and
whatnot like I'm afraid like I stopped
playing the division ready
but part of that's because I don't have
a crew that I run with normally but like
even then it's like your men maxing so
hard on these like pieces of gear and
that's why people are exploiting it's
because like for you to get the best
gear it kind of takes exploiting to get
it because like to do it normally you
just gotta get super lucky and it would
take like forever to be honest and I
don't I don't think they found that
balance yet of like what is good they
keep experimenting and sometimes it's
almost like they have too many knee-jerk
reactions but one of the core gameplay
was more fun that wouldn't be a problem
this wasn't just some like yeah I mean I
don't log of a sheer like it's fun yeah
it's a fine game but like what we're
talking about is that they're like
variable ratio schedule is just don't
work good enough where they're not like
rubbing your belt on our tongue rubbing
your back enough to get you through what
is basically a slog if you're to play it
over and over and over again now you
don't mean like yeah I people play wow
group raids and like like for better or
worse it took six hours of our evenings
and did it like that five days a week
people don't do it on these games
because the gameplay is not there right
because that's not the type of game well
its way that's what seemed like before
this recent patch I actually enjoyed the
gameplay like I mean a granite I had a
pretty good squad I was teaming up with
day in and day out every night you don't
have to work and on the weekends it was
a lot of fun and I thought the gameplay
was like we were just running it was
weird cuz we were running the same
missions a lot you know like these
weekly challenges and like everything
when challenging mode it was super fun
to do but I never felt like it was
really really boring and then this patch
happened and the incursion happened and
then all of a sudden was like well this
game got like insanely it to me at least
it got more difficult yeah and then it
was like okay like eric said the only
way to get this good gear is to do this
at least in an optimal time is to
exploit you know and everyone's doing it
so like what do you do in that situation
do you just follow the same path or do
you try to do it if they Joe if somebody
else jumps off a bridge do you jump off
a bridge ty what's down there that's
specific sick loot anti rude okay thank
you so much for coming on talking the
division course I mean the fact that
we're still talking about the division
of it's always been here for two months
yes there's one thing and you know
really I so can't be all that bad let us
know what you think of the division and
it's glitch festival that's coming up
right now in the comments below all
right gentlemen get your ass out here
all right you're a yeah there might be a
Rob handler in the back believe this is
a jeff gerstmann hiding in the shadows
as well you coming on on yeah joined the
bright shirt party glad to have your
welcome to the new set allowed to be
here I've ducked in here to look at your
new set and it's always all the lights
are on so I look at him go like this
yeah but now you've got it kind of
bright you know shooting space oh yeah
it's kind of cozy yeah it's nice we like
it here rusty yeah exactly yeah mary did
a great job and so did this gentleman
hiding behind me here with his
terrifying camera ah yeah we've got the
SS Pikmin here as well yeah just a sweet
boat yeah it's a real diamond I was
trying to go for like all the words for
boats you know there's like schooner I
got ya kipper mmm that's a capper that a
person yeah skiff I got this gif I don't
know yeah I don't be a specific type of
book it is it's a three-person boat I
rode one den the things I slept in it
for two days things on tames tens i M
yeah yeah okay h's em anyway yeah let's
talk about video games yeah finally
we're gonna talk to you a little bit of
bad that hot scoop yall got over the
office in just a little bit but first of
all the division right I know at
different slightly different very
different online game I know you're a
big fan of the gears of war franchise
you haven't played the beta no no I
watched some footage from the beta Brad
wasn't late it for us so yeah I did
check it out I the competitive
multiplayer is kind of like the least
interesting thing about gears to me
really point so it's sort of like it's a
beta and I think it looks all right but
it's I want to see what they're doing
with cooperative play when I see the
campaign I want to see the future
Phoenix yeah and what he saw the Phoenix
yeah all that stuff yeah you know gears
were kind of just at some point turned
into the rolling shotgun video game and
or maybe kinda always was that and it's
just it's not it's not what I'm looking
for out of competitive multiplayer and
it seems like they're you know like Brad
even said at the event that they kind of
acknowledged that that was the thing and
like gnashing righty time' that cover
based know like literally
rolling really like yeah we're going up
behind someone and shooting it with a
shotgun and they're dead and you're like
well that's not fun yeah so yeah it's
kind of just it's that style of play the
style of play in higher level gears play
is not something i was looking to get
into your seems like their solution for
it is to add better BOTS oh really like
instead of like making the game
friendlier to a wider array of people it
seemed like they were like no gears is
going to stay gears which is probably
the right move but you know you can
always play against bots which is
doesn't sound like a solution yeah
that's one of the three modes they have
on this this beta I played a favor for
about an hour this morning you've plated
you're up to like level 10 yeah i mean i
was i was playing over the weekend and
had issues with just servers people
weren't playing it alright so that's I
gonna happen oh I played a game and then
it'd be like oh there's still a lot of
people here and I realized on it's me
it's just me against bots yeah that was
frustrating but yeah I mean it's it's a
closed press paid at the moment it's
opening up for people who bought
Ultimate Edition in the next couple of
days no I actually misspoke I told you
earlier tis a lot if you have bought an
ultimate dition supposedly you can play
right now it's in early access they're
rolling at the keys apparently yeah so
some people may 25th it's free open beta
hooray yeah on xbox one so you're in the
same boat as Jeff right word you would
like super into the single player in the
series and not worry so much in
multiplayer yeah exactly i mean it was
just co-op you know like my brother and
i played all those that's all was and
and this time around starting off on the
weekend was frustrating because it makes
more sense that you're getting the spill
of all the ultimate edition guys right
playing online heaven totally yeah and
they're just wrecking you yeah and
eventually as i got to lie got my
placement level I ganda they basically
said well you suck so we're putting you
in bronze it's a rocket legal / yeah and
so then I'm getting you know like Tokyo
cup of quad kills like oh this is
getting pretty fun and it is all shotgun
and at its heart it's just a bare-bones
beta experience like you're just getting
these basic weapons like the LT only
introduce one new weapon was to drop
shot right yeah it's like I'm half
minelayer half rocket launch that's a
grenade launcher with like no distances
or those again but regardless f1 skills
fool everyone just run around the
shotgun because you know
it's a power weapon map you know you're
going for power weapons do you want to
go for those all the time do you want to
you know be risky out risk/reward
exactly so it was the one thing I found
actually about it which was I don't know
equal parts sort of like what I was
looking for and also cleared he wasn't
what I really wanted was at this gate
this feels so much like I'm just picking
up gears of war 3 oh my god well like if
you think about the popularity of gears
and like this is kind of one of the
things you could look at like this is
what eSports is doing two games to a
certain extent is like if the rules are
the rules and right you can't make
football suddenly have five downs
instead of four you can't necessarily
like take gears of war and completely
remove the shotgun you know it's popular
enough with a crowd that want to play it
at a high level competitively that you
have to do right by them no matter what
that means for your larger audience yeah
and i think that's that's maybe the the
push and pull of kind of competitive
multiplayer where it's gone when with it
becoming more serious is that you have
more games that are more willing to kind
of leave the wider player base out in
the cold God that seems so strange I'd
like I wonder if there will be a lot of
people who cuz I like I didn't not enjoy
my time with this it was it you know I
got once I figured out like okay I've
you know distance you need to get like a
one shot shotgun Kayla once I you know I
picked up a torque bow and the first
time I fired and I got someone in the
head and I was like all right this still
works like I'm enjoying this and I'm you
know the melee stuff is fun and but then
I was just so taken aback by how this
feels it just too close to before and
yeah but like mate I did not play
Ultimate Edition so I don't know if yes
is very very close to that and also it
is issues like that oh yeah like same
framework that's that those are the
changes they made to ultimate edition
over like the original gears one was
they brought in multiplayer stuff from
like let you know spotting and so many
other stuff that was in you know later
gears games so Ultimate Edition if you
don't like competitive gears it's real
bummer yeah they're competitive gear
scene yes absolutely this gnashing stuff
again is just it's like an exploit that
that I guess was always present in Gears
where you did you just use the cover and
you do this glitch move bouncing up and
down up your hallway and I see that I
don't even know how to respond to it
there so fast I'd like getting around
called cheating the animation of sliding
in and as you know like a there
was a chunk of time there probably
around gears to that I was pretty good
at competitive gear yeah for what it was
at the time Kirsti was great and I guess
got to a point with it was like I'm
actually not really enjoying this like
you know and so I fell away from it and
but people kept on and kept getting
better and better better and better it's
slipping up behind you with that shotgun
I can you blow up and you're like all
right this is actually frustrating what
happens to me I also don't necessarily
enjoy doing it to my people yeah I just
you know I love horde mode right I hope
that they do something good with a wave
based survival or something in years for
and am interested in the story but you
know this this beta just kind of I look
at it and go like okay that's they
they're doing what you only expect them
to do and and that's great for some
segments of people it's just it's just
not for me yeah yeah and you and you
know it was frustrating like last Friday
when they when I got to get the get into
it was you know just putting down
division and moving into that oh my god
control you know I gotta use the d-pad
to switch my weapon like the the thing
that got me the most frustrating was was
frustrated was just the Brody run and
having the camera shake so much like it
makes sense for a cinematic co-op sure
like like level of play when it yeah we
did the competitive nature of it was
like I I can't see anyone and then I
have to slow down and do this really
slow ass off man you just can't take
gear I can't cure I can't wait it was
made yeah for the hardcore East board
game where I kind of I don't know I'm I
think after playing this I'm I realized
that oh actually I may be a bit more
interested in what the single player has
to offer yeah maybe that is actually
where cuz i paid a lot of like gears one
two and three online like i love those
games in pieces and but you're right
like one of the weird things about I
feel like so many shooters is that they
rarely ever change any of the
fundamentals but the one thing at least
to do is try to introduce new game modes
right they can like sort of add in
supplemental ones and they don't
necessarily interfere with the purity
yeah i mean this they've they've added
in auburn cards one yeah which which is
this you're right they've actually did
it but they at least its tone down where
it's just an experience booth right yeah
it's not like dooms where you guys spot
your last
so Ashley yeah yeah whatever was
basically punishes you for getting
people on yeah but they've also added in
this like game mode which is it's it's
basically like I don't they call the
dodgeball right but it's still like I
feel like just the lengthening of play
it's to death match but you know the
rules by which people come back are
different yeah you kill someone you get
a respawn if you got a sizable back yeah
yeah yeah that it does not work in
Europe yeah but not know I was acting
like dodgeball and I was like oh yeah
you have no idea of course the movie
like yes exactly like the mic on okay
that's a middle school gym like
requirement if you can judge if you
knock somebody out you get one of your
guys back in okay that's why it's
dodgeball right which is seams which is
not also also not universal rules for
all forms of doctors well by the way so
let's chew it I was like things where I
kind of think about it go like well
that's never how I played dodgeball like
okay yes okay you hit him so hard that
they could never come back now and we're
coming back there was no coming back so
it just seems like that's like if that's
the one mode you're adding in for the
beta it's like so piecemeal like they've
literally just change like one or two of
those things you know but but at some
point they're actually probably running
a beta rice okay Greg ears game Oh AB
Asia you know they probably need to
actually get some real telemetry they
need to get some proper data from the
people playing it make sure it all works
yeah so at some point you say like yeah
here play the deathmatch mode and gears
a bunch like you're going to do anyway
and we'll be able to make sure that this
thing actually functions yeah so I bet
that there is that aspect to it and they
probably have like a cadence of
marketing releases of where the actual
new modes will come from and all that
stuff so yeah it's not too surprising
that they would just take this beta
angle like look you bought the one that
was the remake of the thing right there
was us getting our legs under us in
making a Gears game for this new
platform what's a year placement
deathmatch I don't know I hope they also
use the beta to make the graphic stuff
up better as well because some of that
stuff's pretty rough yeah well it also
like that was a weird one where we went
to the event and Microsoft provided
capture equipment right and it captured
at 30 frames a second are you kidding
you're like so one thing to get my 720
this is yeah this is your own gear like
this is your own chance to like to make
the game look
as good as it possibly can but you just
pulled out whatever you had in the the
blaze it others from capture hardware
like we own capture equipment that is
capable of capturing writers and but
because they provided it we didn't run
our stuff it was just looking at ago
like I this mistakes were made I dad it
looks very good on the stream at all
just cuz it's in 30 and then also you
got all that compression happening but
even even even just looking at it bear
which I have not done so I've only seen
that footage of it but it sounds like
I've seen stills from it and just looked
at a goalie still not quite like perfect
dark zero wall guys I'm stuff like some
of that looks pretty rough real muddy
which is a shame I mean it it's hard to
expect like the same sort of you know
amazing graphical oomph that came with
like the original gears and gears to
them especially with like those games
dr. Thomas like HD gaming is here and
not to give them like nine more outs but
you know at some point you are
downloading a beta they do have a good
reason try to keep the file size down
for beta because they're paying for all
that bandwidth so maybe they shipped low
res textures you know there's there's a
bunch of different stuff that become
becomes a little harder to judge against
a final game when we're looking at a
beta and I always hate like talking
about betas in these terms but somet so
much of betas it seems now in the modern
day is a bearish marketing is about
getting people played early it's hey you
bought this other game and now what you
get to play this next one early yeah as
otherwise why would you have bought this
contract body react of gears one so um
but on it I mean if it's something to
get people excited then none of us are
particularly excited about at least a
multiplayer side of it ya know I I
really like the teaser trailer with
Margaret Enix dro in that tree yeah well
we did for me using not yet and then
anything in this beta running through
that tree yeah uh but yeah it for so so
at least like coming out of all of this
if you take all of it together right I
am back on board and interested in a
Gears game which is something I would
not have said coming out of judgment
okay yeah hotels the judgment was lame
the most also ran of also runs so so at
least they're kind of there on a track I
can look at this and go like
yeah man gears for let's do it we'll see
where this goes looking forward to
coming out later this year thank you so
much Jeff coming on and talking back
here's before that's why we got you on
here exactly yeah and thanks everyone
for watching no let us know what you
think of Gears of War for Gears of four
are you excited have you played the beta
are you looking forward to getting into
the beta let us know in the comment box
below are you wearing like an IFB where
someone says all right through the
comments is it as I happening this is my
goodness look at it look like it nah man
break these days s just come over right
yes segments naturally you know I'm
reading the comments right here I wasn't
for a while my laptop crashed earlier
but a good job of not showing it nice
although I'm wearing glasses today I
think for the first time I've ever on a
gangster stream so you can probably read
all the secrets coming through cuz this
is he broadcasting in 4k yeah speaking
of 4k 4k Jeff Gerstmann hello you guys
did a good old scoop yesterday yesterday
yes yes yesterday yeah i was reading
this austin walker reporting on a bunch
of stuff that came out of I mean there
was rumors around GDC just people yeah
there's qez McDonald's a hearing people
talk in line about this PlayStation 4.5
yeah and then you guys got a lot more
substantial information yeah yeah we
ended up getting a hold of the specs for
the unit and and some of the is its
developer focused documentation on the
Meo which is a code name for the right
created I want to meet who is coming up
with Sony's code names project morpheus
morpheus now neyo a contributing it's on
the way at some point orbis and beating
all that all the stuff they come back
then linked up in a weird way now they
got this should get our new console the
Nebuchadnezzar right yeah totally um yes
so it was its developer focused
information about how the upgraded
PlayStation 4 codename neo will work and
some of the timing around win third
party games are expected to have that
neo support built right in right so the
specs are what they are i'm not going to
like sit here and recite numbers yeah if
you have them we could talk about jaguar
cores right I know yeah and you guys
talked about on the bombcast a bunch
yeah yes yes but you know it's it's a
it's a better cpu it's a higher higher
clock speed for the cpu it is a
better GPU and it is a higher frequency
for the the ram it seems like the
processor is probably the most biggest
upgrade in that seems oh yeah that's
that's the thing you kind of hear about
being maybe a bottleneck for some of the
existing PlayStation 4 games so that
might be something that where that would
put see some benefit cool but I'm not
necessarily like mr. graphics mr.
technical um so for me like looking over
this stuff it seems interesting kind of
the positioning of it and what they are
and aren't allowing developers to do
with the games so you like there will be
no neo exclusive games right in the
documentation straight up says that yeah
yeah this will be this will be an
upgraded version of the PlayStation 4 it
will play your existing games it will
and it will also play games that are
that will run differently on an upgraded
ps4 as opposed to the original ps4 but
every disc you buy will work in both so
developers will have to comic come up
with like two versions of the specs yeah
and the neo is kind of built for 4k at
least the display resolution it'll have
a scalar that it can output to 4k TVs
but that doesn't necessarily mean that
games will run give Lee at 4k because
that's something that pcs have a hard
time right I mean 4k is like it's it's
at least four times as much as 10 it's
like it's an incredible amount it really
hard it's the sort of thing where you
have like two or three graphics cards in
a PC like when when Microsoft first
showed that free forts a thing right
running they were like the surrounding
at 4k and you look behind the guy giving
a demo and there's just this mountain
piece clear case like oh just straight
out of a rich man's land party uh and
and yeah it's you know it's it's a hard
thing to do right now it won't always be
I mean you know in videos getting ready
to announce more stuff everything's
always getting more powerful but if
they're saying 4k in the documentation
there must be a reason why they're
saying for okay so is that Sony being
Sony and trying to you know well so that
everything will probably scale I mean
you know all these consoles now have a
scalar in them that will output whatever
resolution you tell it to regardless of
the native resolution so then in the
documents they kind of provide some
potential options for developers making
games and working in neo mode or as
opposed to base mode which is what they
were going to the Richards forced open
loop
revelation called um so in in neo mode
games are expected to you know output 4k
and and render at a resolution no lower
than 1080 right so they're kind of
saying like here's some different ways
to kind of achieve handling outputting
to 4k while still detecting if there's
not a 4k TV plugged in and making sure
you're doing stuff at 1080 properly and
so they're kind of providing a few
different options based on I assume
their early work on developing games for
this thing as kind of a way forward for
third parties but you know this is
basically still the PlayStation 4 your
account will come over all of your games
and saves will come over your PSN
account like all the stuff you would
expect to come right in comes right in
controllers will work all that sort of
stuff so it's really more about this
kind of neo mode concept so as of
October games that are hitting the
streets in October developers shipping
games will be expected to be supporting
neo mode right then and there expected
that is that will be part of the
requirements to ship a PlayStation 4
game ice well as of October
late-september you will be expected to
have a day one patch enabling the 0 mode
ok all right none of these documents
actually refer to a release date for the
device and they do in fact say that
they're okay with the idea of developers
shipping neo supporting games ahead of
the release of the upgraded console ok
so we can't necessarily pin this down
and say well obviously the consoles come
in October but it probably won't come
out before october right it could be
early next year you know we don't really
know but it says their holiday console
then this is could be yeah or it could
be a q1 console I don't know okay we
won't know until they officially start
talking about it which they still
haven't done yeah um so yeah that that's
kind of the the interesting stuff you
know their requirements include stuff
like in neo mode the game must run at at
least to the same frame rate it's not
better than the the base mode version of
the game developers at will at you know
developers that have games on the market
already or games that are shipping
before late-september they will have the
option to patch neo support into their
games and I can think of a few games
that that would be great for Christ
fallout 4 would make off would maybe
benefit from that
shin forward uh and and that sort of
stuff will kind of see how developers
take to that if the passions of being a
lot of work and the game's not super
popular I don't really see a lot of
reason for developers to go back and do
that work yeah but those games will
still run on a neo the Neo can't run in
base mode so all that software still
runs and it should with what they're
saying we'll see how it goes it should
run just as it does on your existing
PlayStation 4 today interesting what
about uh neo features because there's a
mention of like you know no there won't
be a rocket League special car in real
mode rise but then awesome continued and
said but what might happen is a local
four player co-op could be present and
then hey maybe neo mode can do a player
co-op right co-op offline also that's
the that's the the specifics there you
can't as a developer you wouldn't be
able to say hey if you have a neo you'll
have a higher player count online this
is 32 players on neo 16 on ps4 online
you can't segregate the user base at all
along those lines you can't have neo
exclusive features so but you can't have
enhanced versions of those features that
may run in neo boats that's why the the
the local multiplayer thing happens the
mode exists on the base ps4 but is a
four player mode right but on neo maybe
it's an eighth player mode it's not a
wording yeah yeah is that not a feature
yeah well I guess yes it is but they're
saying like the mode must exist in some
form it can't be like perfect dark
without the expansion pack where it's
like I know you can't play any of this
stuff without this thing it's more like
you can play everything with a base ps4
but in some cases you may be able to say
like oh well we've raised the player
count in this offline mode because they
can't segregate the online mode so they
can't do it there and that was more
provided as an example or something that
a developer could do as opposed to like
i don't i don't know that this will
actually come to pass no but you know
like so you couldn't do VR only on the
neo ok would have to support it in both
places you can't do exclusive modes but
you could enhance your existing modes as
long as it doesn't segregate the user
basis this isn't going to impact the
breakout box thing we
with the PlayStation 4 we don't know
about that either so there there really
isn't any mention of VR in the stuff
that we've seen so I I would think that
they would build that breakout box into
the console at this point but maybe
that's a cost thing that they just don't
want to do and and all that sort of
stuff yeah it remains to be seen but
that breakout box there's no real power
in that thing for games it's ness it's
just kind of necessary for the VR stuff
to work so one way or the other it kind
of doesn't matter it would just be more
of a convenience thing the same way that
if you tried to hook connect up to a
launch 360 right you had to use external
power whereas the later 360s just had
the connector port right on it yeah so
it seems like it'd be sort of like that
difference it's I mean it sounds from
what you were talking about that they're
taking all the right boxes that they're
like doing right by the current
consumers but also upgrading this other
one yeah but is there an argument to be
said that if they took the shackles off
a little bit when it comes to the older
people who already own a playstation 4
and i'm a playstation 4 owner myself
who's placing forward literally broke
over the weekend or last week who so
this was like I know you're in a tough
spot right what do you do and like if
they were to care less about current
owners then they could really yeah do
something with this does it feel like
it's a little bit tame I it's it feels
this feels like these are the these are
the mandates today and these are the
mandates for launch right and I think
what happens two years from now what
happens a year from now will depend on
what the makeup of consoles in the
marketplace is hmm you know if if a
bunch of these Neos sell to the point
where that's the dominant version of the
console then maybe in a year maybe in
two years they go like all right we're
gonna we're going to relax some of these
restrictions yeah yeah you can maybe
push further into neo exclusive
territory I mean they did that with the
was the xbox with the arcade version
were originally the hard drive on that
Union yeah you know it all it takes with
with Microsoft with stuff like that all
it took was a first party game getting
waved a lot of common things so every
time a halo would come out and do
something that other third-party games
were not allowed to do every third party
would go like well you did it for them
right so we're doing it now and there we
go okay so I you know we'll see how that
stuff goes but I think it makes sense
for out of the gate to not alienate
existing
and I but I do agree that it seems like
if they didn't have that restriction
maybe you could lean into the power a
little bit more yeah a little bit more
out of it but at the same time these
numbers are higher but I don't know that
they're like not the world crushingly hi
you know you're not gonna like take your
like built pc and throw it out a window
now I got a neo but yeah I don't know
it's a weird spot and I think that all
of video games is in a really weird
terapia between this happening with
everything Microsoft's trying to do
pushing onto the pc in weird ways that
aren't always great yeah and what VR is
starting to do two things or what wants
people I can actually get a headset with
that what that may do to just video
games in general like we're we're
entering strange uncharted territory
yeah nobody seems like they're uneven
feet at the moment yeah even you know
you look at Sony like you would expect
them to be like hey there the market
leader like they're they're kind of able
to determine a certain cadence they can
kind of sit back a little bit there you
know they're doing the thing that like
all console manufacturers do just in a
different way they're getting to this
point where hey we found ways to make
the existing console it in a more
inexpensive way but instead of like
turning that into pure profit for them
by just you know retooling their
internals yeah they're going like well
as part of that process we can actually
make it more powerful so why don't we do
that too that's a massive twist the
knife in Microsoft's back there I like
what what does it what does somebody
coming up this Christmas somebody wants
to buy a console nay for whatever reason
having pick one up yeah this late in the
game but this deep in like the Xbox one
becomes a much more difficult
proposition I this thing I think so too
but we don't know what Microsoft is up
to right you know like Phil Spencer back
there spring showcase not that long ago
was kind of alluding to the idea of an
upgradeable console and this was also in
context of like hey quanta brakes coming
to pc and i fully expect that from here
on out every first party xbox game will
appear on the pc i got a message give me
a free version of it cuz i right you
know they'll do like a cross by
different pre-orders that's just water
yeah cooperate yeah so they're they're
trying to kind of pull whatever levers
they can to get more excitement around
their games and get get a bigger
audience you know putting that stuff on
the pc maybe mitigate some of the
a a lot of the them being a bit behind
the ps4 yeah or it can but but we don't
know what they're doing with the Xbox
platform other than probably turning it
more and more into a brand obviously
there's an Xbox app on Windows 10 right
there they have multiple games you think
of as xbox games in the windows 10 store
now it seems like they'll continue to
lean into that so why won't they then
also have an upgraded console at some
point too I mean the division able
looted to some of that stuff and then
Spencer kind of backed away from it a
little bit and said you know I think the
quote was something along the lines of
like I'm not going to ship someone a
screwdriver in a video card right you
know which obviously no but you might
sell them a more powerful Xbox console
at some point down the line which all of
this at some point adds up to why
wouldn't you just buy a PC yeah that's
exactly how high they don't i'd be like
they're more they're certainly more
expensive to build if you don't have one
today but if you're not the reasons not
to the reasons to have a consult I'm not
to have a PC which existed 10 years ago
don't exist anymore yeah ever all the
big console games are going MPC yeah not
so much oh BTW stuff is everywhere
positive life stuff is so much better on
pc never was before yeah there's less
like [ __ ] when it comes to hardware
and there ever was before I mean they're
still [ __ ] but like it's you know
saying with the way steam is being run
you know those games go on sale a lot so
it's more expensive up front but I bet
if you're smart about it it kind of
balances out in the end it's not for
everyone i mean some people just sit
down put a disc in a thing and play and
PCs are still not that you know go get a
steam box and tell me if that it's that
not even that it's not a good feeling
like pc i've went at home and i plan on
it upgrading that soon but you know you
throw in fallout 4 i got tone it down
all the way and it's like I would this
could be better and I was just playing
like a game yesterday on ps4 and now
it's like what I imagine down the road
is man I wonder how cool or how much
better this would rise if I had the neo
that's a very frustrating thing cuz
that's what you buy a console and you
last you for five years now you're like
cool everyone's got the same especially
you imagine someone who bought a ps4 for
the first time this week yeah you know
like my brother at convinced him last
week to get a ps4 yeah
yeah that's in and you know hey if you
think about when the new Nintendo 3ds
came out you know right somebody's like
gamestop we're lining up to give you a
decent chunk of money for your existing
3ds as part of an upgrade transaction
you would have to imagine they would be
doing something like that and there's
even a potential case to be made for
Sony to try to do some kind of thing for
their existing right consumer base but I
don't know about that I mean the worst
thing I can think of right now is the
developers come out with like neo
versions of their games which are like
you know falling for neo mo version and
it works on the old one too yeah we've
optimized it so it'll work even better
on that and then try to sell it instead
of patching it yeah that's yeah that I
if I were Sony that would be the first
thing I would say you absolutely cannot
do this will we will not allow you to do
this you have to patch your existing
game if you're going to sell a game of
the year edition no though because they
can't afford to that that that would
anger people that that would be probably
a bit over the line yeah with something
that already seems a little shaky but
yeah I'm curious to see what they say
about it when they do start talking
about all this stuff and and how they
attempt to position it because I think
it is it's an awkward move where yeah
you've got the the high end is it is it
truly high enough if they have to be
hamstrung by the the you know the the
previous console and if you just bought
the previous console are you gonna
suddenly start getting 20 frames a
second on all your games because
everyone optimizing for neo first and
foremost it's a it's a weird road to
walk down I kind of understand why they
might have chosen to do this because
it's not like the consoles we're all
that powerful to begin with right they
might be getting tapped out might not
have been able to make it five years
yeah but yeah it's it's like I said it's
a real weird time e3's gonna be exciting
yeah guess that stuff and we got
Nintendo yeah you know so n NX is gonna
come out there and be like here's our
left-field thing that doesn't even
factor into whatever these idiots we're
our own idiot you know they like that
that's it's really exciting it's great
as long as that Mario maker rumor turns
out to be true as long as there's a new
mario maker or port of moria annual
you're gonna annualized franchise like
they always been sick this one's got
three new mushrooms
great yeah less than two months until
you three exciting times who knows how
many new consoles would be staring down
the barrel off in just over two months
time Jeff Chrisman thank you so much for
coming on and people want to hear more
about your breaking story on the oh they
can go to giant bomb and the broadcast
as well yeah giantbomb.com the podcast
is up right now you could be listening
to it right now he could be but don't
this isn't the end of it yeah it's
almost over raavan Louie thank you so
much for coming on thank you I really
appreciate it we'll get you back out
there thank you so much to Richard Lee
almost fell over walking out his ass out
of here with steady cam and Mary kisses
well running today and doing a crazy
manner work she's off to pax tomorrow I
believe or if not the next day with a
bunch of GameSpot folks they'll be ro
ran the clock coverage coming out of
Boston Convention Center from Friday all
the way through the weekend does a show
and on Monday no no that one sunday is
just a prime is the one round-the-clock
coverage of this thing that there's very
little news I know yeah are you're not
going cuz your valves all messed up yeah
that's it that's a that's one of a
number of good excuses why I shouldn't
be doing anything right now we're going
out we're all going out thursday so we
are cool as well awesome great check out
all the panels above all the information
on that via the various social media
streams I'm gonna go put ice on my face
thank you so much for watching today's
show thank you so much Eric day in the
back as well for running up the show we
will see you next time Tuesday 2 p.m.
pacific right here on gamespot com have
a good week